the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another song of ice and fire
video
in one of my recent videos i went over
ned stark's first chapter in the book a
game of thrones
during that video i highlighted some of
the evidence from the chapter that i
believe
shows who is next in line for the iron
throne as you all know
after viserys dies we are led to believe
daenerys is the only other targaryen
in the line of succession but we
eventually find out jon snow has a
legitimate claim as well
this was confirmed in the game of
thrones television show now i think most
of us believe this will also happen in
the books
however there are a lot of fans who
think this was only done for the show
some of the a song of ice and fire fans
say
jon snow is not the son of rhaegar and
lyanna
now i don't agree with that at all so i
thought i would make this video for
everyone who hasn't read the books
i want to show you all the references i
found that i think
indicates jon snow is the next one in
line for the throne
i hope you find some of these references
as interesting as i did
because george rr martin is a genius at
hiding these right under our nose
in fact george rr martin is so good at
this i might have missed some
but i think i will show you more than
enough evidence to back it up
shall we begin now there is a very good
chance that bran stark could become the
final king of westeros in the books
like he did in the show however that
does not mean he is the next one in line
if this happens in the books it will
most likely be because jon isn't able to
for whatever reason the secrets to some
of the biggest mysteries in a song of
ice and fire
were most likely laid out to us in the
very first book
i think some of the most interesting
details were even laid out to us in some
of the very first chapters
for those of you who did not see my last
video this is set up for us
in ned stark's first chapter when robert
baratheon arrives in winterfell
as robert and ned are heading down to
see lyanna statue
robert talks about how he barely noticed
anyone outside as he made his journey
north
ned says everyone was most likely too
shy to come out to see their king
then he says kings are a rare sight in
the north
robert then says more likely they were
hiding under the snow
now you could take this at face value
but if you read between the lines
you will see that george r martin is
slowly revealing jon snow secret
right after ned says kings are a rare
sight in the north robert says
more likely they were hiding under the
snow i think that means there is a king
in the north hiding under the name snow
as in jon snow it's no coincidence
this is said raiders robert and ned are
on their way to see lyanna
ned was able to hide this secret right
under everyone's nose
by hiding him under the name snow that
might not mean very much to you by
itself
but let's see what else we can find in
jon snow's first chapter
he has a conversation with his uncle
benjen about joining the night's watch
benjen doesn't want jon to give up
everything in his life right away
he essentially says jon is still too
young to make that decision
john says daryon targaryen was only 14
when he conquered dorne
the young dragon was one of his heroes
his uncle benjen reminds him that daryon
also died by the age of 18. now this
might not mean that much at first either
but i find it very interesting that
george r martin wrote this in john's
very first chapter
we can see that jon has a connection to
a targaryen who was able to achieve
things at a very young age
just like jon but then he ended up dead
at a very young age
just like john as well the young dragon
is one of john's heroes
while jon might also be a young dragon
himself
now let's look at something from tyrion
lannister second chapter
when john and tyrion are on their way to
the wall together they set up camp for
the night to get some sleep
this is when john notices tyrion is
reading a book it's a book that just so
happens to be about dragons
and what makes this even more
interesting is the fact that tyrion
might be a targaryen as well
there is more than enough evidence to
support that theory and maybe i'll even
make a video where i show all the
evidence for tyrion being a targaryen
but for now let's stick to jon as tyrion
is reading the book about dragons
he tells jon when i was your age i used
to dream of having a dragon of my own
then he says don't look at me that way
bastard i know your secret
you have dreamt the same kind of dreams
i happen to feel like this is the author
speaking directly to us
john is not the bastard we think we know
in jon snow's fourth chapter
he's at the wall john and sam are having
a conversation about their dreams
like we saw in the show sam tells john
about how his father made him join the
night's watch
sam's father essentially tells him he's
not welcome at home
this leads john to telling sam about his
dream and how it left him feeling the
same way
jon says the old kings of winter are
down there
sitting on their throne with their stone
wolves at their feet and iron swords
across their laps
but it's not them i'm afraid of i scream
that i'm not a stark
that this isn't my place but it's no
good i have to go anyway
so i start down filling the walls as i
descend
with no torch to light the way now at
first
this may seem like jon isn't welcome
down there because he's a bastard
and as we all know bastards do not get
their own statues in the crypts of
winterfell
but i think it means more than just that
i think he's really not welcome down
there because he's a targaryen
but he still has this sense that he has
to go down there anyway
and i think that's because although he
is a targaryen his mother lyanna
is still down there below the castle he
has to find out the truth
one way or another now the next one i
want to show you was very well hidden
you would have to be looking very
closely to spot it this is when serio
pharrell has arya chasing cats around
the red keep in king's landing
raid azaria is chasing this cat she runs
into one of the gold cloaks from the
city watch
this is what it says one by one arya had
chased them down and snatched them up
and brought them to serio pharrell
all but this one this one-eared black
devil of a tomcat
that's the real king of this castle
right there one of the gold cloaks that
told her
older than sin and twice as mean one
time
the king was feasting the queen's father
and that black bastard hopped up on the
table
and snatched a rose quail right out of
lord tywin's fingers
now actually think about what that gold
cloak said he referred to the cat as
the real king of the castle and a black
bastard
what character do we know that might be
considered a black bastard
who also might be the real king of that
castle in king's landing
you would be right if you guessed jon
snow john is well known as a bastard
but since he is now in the night's watch
he is also known as a black brother
or a brother in black or a man in black
he is a black bastard
who is the real king of the castle the
way this was woven in here as just
another throwaway line is genius
let's go ahead and move on to another
one of ned stark's chapters
this is when littlefinger takes ned to
see who john aaron spoke to before he
died
it was the mother of one of robert
baratheon's bastards
if you remember from the show
littlefinger takes ned to see her in his
brothel
this is when ned is realizing all of
robert's bastards have black hair
unlike his so-called children by cersei
this scene is different in the books
because now we get to see ned stark's
thoughts as it's happening
what he thinks about is very interesting
the mother of robert's child says
tell robert how beautiful she is i will
ned had promised her he then thought of
the promises he made lyanna
as she lay dying and the price he paid
to keep them
i will tell him child and i promise you
barra shall not go wanting
she had smiled then a smile so tremulous
and sweet that it cut the heart right
out of him
riding through the rainy night ned saw
jon snow's face in front of him
so like a younger version of his own
this is not a coincidence either
right after ned thinks aleana he can see
jon snow's face
this is obviously because lyanna reminds
him of jon
they have those stark features just like
ned why else would ned be thinking about
the promise he made lyanna
right as he's looking at one of robert's
bastards who also has to be kept in the
shadows
ned thinks about all this because he had
to do the same thing with john
and that's why he sees his face right
after he ends the conversation
now what makes it even more interesting
is what ned thinks about next
after he thinks about lyanna and john he
then thinks about rehgar
imagine that it says for the first time
in years
he found himself remembering rhaegar
targaryen he wondered if rhaegar had
frequented the brothels
but somehow he thought not you see
lyanna's death was such a traumatic
event in ned stark's life that he
actually doesn't remember a whole lot
from that day
he does remember what happened leading
up to her death
but once he's holding her lifeless body
he doesn't really remember much after
that
he has been able to block it out but the
cider robert's bastard has ned
remembering things
he hasn't thought of in years all of
this reminds him of what happened the
day he found lyanna
inside a tower and dorne this makes him
think of jon and rhaegar as well
and we all know why let's look at
another one
this is from the second book of clash of
kings in one of john's chapters
he and lord commander mormont have a
conversation about maester aymond's life
as you all know jon figures out that
maester aemon is a targaryen
so lord commander mormon talks to him
about this and some of the recent
targaryen kings
neither of them have any idea that jon
is actually related to all of them
and he is the next one in line for that
iron throne anyways
john and his lord commander talk about
maester aemon's father
and his brothers and the mad king but
then
once again something very interesting
happens
lord commander mormont says jaime
lannister
ended the line of dragon kings when he
killed the mad king
in the books lore commander mormont has
a raven and during this conversation
his raven croaks the word king then the
raven flapped across the solar to land
on mormont's shoulder
king it said again strutting back and
forth
he likes that word john said smiling
mormont stroked the raven under the beak
with a finger but all the wow his eyes
never left jon snow
now actually think about that right as
they are having a conversation about the
different targaryen kings and how they
were all dead
mormont's raven locks his eyes on jon
snow and says the word king
over and over again without his eyes
ever leaving jon
now we all know the three-eyed crow is
inside that raven
and we all know the three-eyed crow
knows everything he's letting us know
who the real king is after all
this is george r martin's way of
speaking directly to us
but also leaving it somewhat open
because some will say it's a bird that
doesn't know anything
let's have another look from one of
john's chapters this is said when jon
and egard are together
after she finds out jon is the bastard
of winterfell
she tells him a story that has a very
obvious connection to his own
this is what it says bail the bar made
it said ygritte
he was king beyond the wall a long time
back
all the free folk know his songs but
might be you don't sing them in the
south
the stark in winterfell wanted bale's
head but never could take him and the
taste of failure gauled him
one day in his bitterness he called bale
a craven who prayed only on the weak
when word of that got back bale vowed to
teach the lord a lesson
so he scaled the wall skipped down the
king's road and walked into winterfell
one winter's night with his harp in hand
naming himself sigurik of skagos segurik
means deceiver
in the old tongue that the first men
spoke and the giants still speak north
or south
singers always find a ready welcome so
bale ate at the lord stark's own table
and played for the lord in his high seat
until half the night was gone
it's said that he played in saying so
well that when he was done
the lord offered to let him name his own
reward all i ask for is a flower
bale answered the ferrous flower that
blooms in the gardens of winterfell
so the stark sent to his glass gardens
and commanded that the most beautiful
winter roses be plucked for the singer's
payment
and so it was done but when the morning
come the singer had vanished
and so had lord brandon's maiden
daughter her bed they found empty
but for the pale blue rose that bale had
left on the pillow where her head had
lain
jon had never heard this tale before
lord brandon had no other children
for most a year they searched for any
sign of bail or dismayed
till the lord lost heart and took to his
bed and it seemed as though the line of
starks was at its end
but one night as he was lay waiting to
die lord brandon heard a child's cry
he followed the sound and found his
daughter back in her bed chamber
asleep with a babe at her breast they
had been in winterfell
all the time hiding with the dead
beneath the castle
the maid loved bale so dearly she bore
him a son
the song says now let's look at the
connections here
because this story sounds very similar
to rhaegar leona and john's
bale the bard could play the harp very
well just like rhaegar
bale the bard asks the lord of
winterfell for a blue winter rose
that he ends up giving to the daughter
of winterfell this is the same kind of
blue rose rhaegar gave lyanna
at the taurenia harrenhal then bale the
bard and heard disappeared
and they had a son together this is what
rhaegar and lyanna did as well
and this son ends up becoming the
bastard of winterfell just like jon snow
it's no coincidence that when we learn
of this story it's in jon snow's chapter
now sometime after ygritte tells john
this story
he begins to question who he really is
in another one of john's chapters
this is what it says i never meant to
steal you he said
i never knew you were a girl until my
knife was at your throat
if you kill a man and never meant he's
just as dead
yeegart said stubbornly john had never
met anyone so stubborn
except maybe for his little sister arya
is she still my sister he wondered
was she ever well john the answer is no
now you could obviously look at this a
few different ways but i happen to
believe george rr martin is guiding us
in a certain direction with john's
storyline
this next one i want to show you is most
likely foreshadowing two different
things let's look at the prologue and
dance with dragons
now this chapter is from the perspective
of veramir sixgins who is a member of
the free folk who knows how to skin
change into several different animals
he's more or less the zookeeper out
beyond the wall
well in this chapter veramir has been
stabbed
and he knows he's about to die so he
looks for someone or something to skin
change into
so his conscious can live on in
something else as he is thinking about
what he will do next
he begins to think about jon snow and
his direwolf ghost
this is what it says he had known what
snow was the moment he saw
that great white direwolf stalking
silent at his side
one skin changer can always sense
another man should have let me take the
direwolf
there would be a second life worthy of a
king
he could have done it he did not doubt
the gift was strong in snow
but the youth was untaught still
fighting his nature
when he should have gloried in it now i
want you to focus on this one line
when veramir says there would be a
second life
worthy of a king alright for those of
you that haven't read the books you
might not know this
but jon snow is able to skin change into
ghost just like brain does with summer
all of the stark children have that
ability in the books since veramir is a
skin changer
he's able to sense the same ability in
john and he notices this while jon and
mance are together
this chapter is foreshadowing what jon
will have to do once he dies at the end
of this book
this is shortly before jon is stabbed by
his own men at the night's watch
right before jon dies he will have to go
inside ghost
then eventually go back inside his own
body if it can be saved through magic or
something else
vermeer six skins not only foreshadows
what jon will have to do when he dies
but he also foreshadows
jon's biggest secret when he thinks
there would be a second life worthy of a
king
as we all know ghost is not your average
wolf
varamir thinks ghost is so special only
a king is worthy of skin changing into
him for a second life
he's actually right jon snow is a secret
king
and he will use ghosts for a second life
at least for a short period of time
now i want to look at what maester amen
said to jon when they last spoke
he gave jon some final advice and this
is what he said
egg had an innocence to him a sweetness
we all loved
kill the boy within you i told him the
day i took ship for the wall
it takes a man to roll an aegon not an
egg
kill the boy and let the man be born the
old man felt john's face
you are half the age that egg was and
your own burden
is a crueler one i fear you will have
little joy of your command
but i think you have the strength in you
to do the things that must be done
kill the boy jon snow winter is almost
upon us
kill the boy and let the man be born
maester ayman can obviously sense
something within jon
something that reminds him of aegon this
makes the second time mr amen gave that
advice
he gave it to one aegon many years ago
then right before he dies
he feels the need to give it again to
another aegon targaryen
well jones real name was aegon targaryen
in the show but it might be slightly
different in the book
either way i don't think this is a
coincidence
now if there is only one reference to
jon being a king
or one instance of jon having a
connection to a targaryen
then i could easily dismiss it as a
coincidence but this happens in every
single book
there has to be a good reason why the
author is telling us something
alright now this next one was a little
harder to find you will have to read
between the lines to see it
at the beginning of game of thrones
robert baratheon is the king of westeros
and before robert baratheon became king
there was
ares targaryen also known as the mad
king who ran the seven kingdoms
robert baratheon was known as a drunk
and the mad king was known as a madman
let me show you what i mean in a dance
with dragons it says
barristan selmy could not dispute that
he had spent the best part of his own
life
obeying the commands of drunkards and
madmen
obviously barristan was a member of the
kingsguard for robert
and the mad king we hear tywin lannister
make the same reference in the show
he says to jaime you served as a
glorified bodyguard for two kings
one a madman the other a drunk
what have you done with these blessings
huh
you've served as a glorified bodyguard
for two kings
one a madman the other are drunk
now let's look at something very
interesting from one of john's chapters
it says john laughed laughed like a
drunk or a madman
and his men laughed with him this is
another example of george rr martin
hiding the secret right under our nose
now john might not be a drunk or a
madman but he does have a connection to
the mad king and robert baratheon
he is and or will be a king just like
them
let me show you something else from a
clash of kings when jon meets gilly at
craster's key
this is when gilly is looking for some
help it says
her breath frosted the air in small
nervous puffs
they say the king gives justice and
protects the weak
she started to climb off the rock
awkwardly but the ice had made it
slippery and her foot went out from
under her
john caught her before she could fall
and helped her safely down
the woman knelt on the icy ground
alright now let's look at this a little
closer
gilly says the king gives justice and he
protects the weak
this is immediately followed up by jon
saving gilly from hitting
the ground he protects the weak when he
does this for gilly
it says she kneels down on the icy
ground she kneels before him
as if he's a king now maybe this is
nothing at all
or maybe it means john is a king who
does what one should
okay now let's look at one more that i
want to show you
and i think this one is very interesting
as well
in order to see this first we have to
look at one of davos's chapters
it says the lady melisandre tells us
sometimes relor
permits his faithful servants to glimpse
the future and the flames
it seemed to me as i watched the fire
this morning that i was looking at a
dozen beautiful dancers
maidens garbed in yellow silk spinning
and swirling before a great king
i think it was a true vision sir a
glimpse of the glory that awaits his
grace after we take king's landing
and the throne that is his by right now
make sure you remember what he saw in
the fire
he was able to see beautiful maiden
dancers garbed in yellow
swirling and spinning in front of a
great king let's see what it says
jon snow sees later in the same book it
says
john went out to cut more branches
snapping each and two before tossing it
into the flames
the tree had been dead a long time but
it seemed to live again in the fire
as fiery dancers woke within each stick
of the wood to whirl and spin in their
glowing gowns of yellow
red and orange now you can see what
great king this was happening in front
of
sir axel florent was not able to see the
king's face
but he could see the dancers wearing
yellow spinning around in the fire
then as jon looked in those flames it
seemed as
if the fire was dancing and spinning in
yellow red and orange
right in front of him this is
fascinating stuff ladies and gentlemen
as i said before at the beginning of the
video bran stark may become the king
like he did in the show but we all know
who the rightful king really is
and that is john mother freaking snow
leave me your thoughts down below i have
a bunch of different videos in the works
so make sure you are on the lookout for
those i will be releasing videos more
frequently
now that i have all the new equipment
that i needed i am very excited so i
hope to see you all back here for those
videos as well
as always i want to thank everyone for
watching this video
and i also want to thank everyone for
supporting me on patreon
have a great day i will see you again
very soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
you